le mouvement pour le droit des femmes
est en pleine effervescence dans les
années 60 elles viennent notamment
d'obtenir le droit universel à la
contraception
mais l'accès à l'avortement n'est pas
encore un droit reconnu pour toutes les
américaines l'histoire légal d'euros
contre wade elle commence au texas en
1966 norma mccorvey 22 ans veut se faire
avorter mais son état le permet
seulement si la vie de la femme est en
danger ce qui n'est pas son cas ses
avocats contestent alors la
constitutionnalité de cette loi anti
avortement y poursuivre l'état du texas
jinro c'est le pseudonyme choisi pour
préserver l'anonymat de leurs clients
inwi wade et le procureur de dallas
norma mccorvey ans le temps d'accoucher
de son enfant et de le faire adopter
avant que sa cause ne se retrouve devant
la cour suprême jeudi
22 janvier 1973
sept juges contre deux tranches en
faveur d'une interprétation de la
constitution ou le droit à la vie privée
d'une femme qui souhaite se faire
avorter prime sur les lois des états
[Musique]
dans sa décision la cour balises
toutefois l'intervention elle est
accessible pour tout pendant le premier
trimestre
après son accès peut être restreint si
l'avortement est jugé dangereux pour la
femme l'intervention peut être internet
seulement à la toute fin de la grossesse
est en souffrance que les écuyers un
mois aux chinois eux de temps à fait
normal car il dévoile sont identiques
dans les années 90 est créé la surprise
il trouve son salut dans la religion est
joint les rangs du mouvement anti
avortement
revirement sur son lit de mort la femme
alors âgée de 69 ans dit avoir été payée
pour militer contre l'avortement
norma mccorvey meurt en 2017
et cinq ans plus tard la cause qui porte
son nom résonne encore si pascal
harrison julien radio-canada m'ont rien